so we've used a human voice as a
synthesizer
there's pat's coming there there's all
sorts of excitement going on
you want to suck the crowd into that
moment
now it comes the payoff
everything in dance music revolves
around the kick drum it's your guidance
it's the holy grail
we roll off all the low end it just adds
to the
transients if your kick is not working
it won't rock a crowd you'll you'll find
that out the hard way
[Music]
i've done a gain automation my tracks
3db
softer so that's an arrangement trick to
tell people okay guys
it's coming it's coming it's coming
bam so that's how you build a drop i
started to dj
in this really really small club
sometimes i even had to bartend while i
was spinning
i put on my new song and then nothing
happens on the dance floor
so you go back into the studio until
it's perfect
are you ready to do a couple of takes
[Music]
she woke up in the morning
i want to create a track completely from
scratch especially for this master class
with my good friend benno
keep it at the same note you want to
make it shorter well let's see let's try
and see
it was really my passion you know making
little mixtapes for my friends and
i'm still that little kid you know that
hasn't changed if that passion is real
it will come across it's about you you
are
your own sound if you're standing behind
the decks and you're shining
and you're having an amazing time it'll
have an effect on people
you can get there trust me
[Music]
i'm army van buren and this is my master
class
you